right here with reaction to tonight's
news opening monologue Judicial Watch
president tom Fitton and former deputy
assistant to the president Fox News
national security strategist Sebastian
Gorka dr. korkor there's so much to
unravel here on so many different levels
and what we're really beginning to see
is that more and more there's evidence
that this goes back to the Obama
administration and even the president
knew that the Susan Rice memo to self is
very revealing to me yeah absolutely
I mean it's so transparent it simply
talks to you know the ability or the
inability to be subtle about a cover-up
when you're no longer than national
security adviser let me just make one
comment I was listening to your
monologue and and something occurred to
me listening to the last segment robert
muller was empowered to do what to
investigate whether there was collusion
whatever that is between the Trump
campaign and Russia the rod Rosenstein
press conference last week started with
what statements Shaun there is no
evidence that despite what Russia did
there was any effect on the election
that's how he started so what are we
talking about why are we spending
millions of dollars the Kremlin are bad
guys vetting they're putting the former
KGB officer I get it but if you start
with the assertion nothing happened that
changed the election then why don't you
dissolve the whole office of the Special
Counsel look it's that that should have
happened a long time ago
and he should never have been allowed to
put this abusively by his team together
Tom let me read you something this is
from the do Jay's announcement from last
Friday when they actually went out and
said when they said the indictment
includes eight criminal counts and
criminal conspiracy to fraud the u.s.
the defendants allegedly conspired to
defraud the US by impairing the lawful
functions of the FEC the US Department
of Justice u.s. Department of State in
administrating federal requirements of
disclosure for foreign involvement in
certain domestic activities I want to
ask this in relation to Russia's point
which I thought was brilliant which was
wait a minute
they would have done it in this
particular case that means Hillary
that means fusion that means Christopher
steel that means everyone else would
have the same standards would have
applied so while they talk broadly about
it in the indictment and they mention it
in their press release that's not what
heat they were charged with do you see
that that was done purposely yeah I
think it was a fundamentally dishonest
document designed to distract from the
fact that the Russia collusion
allegations against Donald Trump are
collapsing and the reason for being of
the Muller investigation is disappearing
and you've got the offending in many
ways the Obama administration reacted
appropriately to what the Russians were
doing as alleged in this indictment
because they were having an immaterial
impact on our public policy process they
should have been stole told to stop
messing around which evidently they were
but they weren't spending a lot of money
and they were having zero impact but on
the other hand they were also messing
around significantly by trying to
destroy Donald Trump through this
dossier leaking through Russian
intelligence services to the Clinton
campaign that laundered it into the
Obama DOJ and FBI and rather than
respond appropriately and protect mr.
Trump from this smear effort by the
Russians that you notice it as a pretext
to target and spy on him and his team
and that is where that's the scandal and
the fundamentals about scandal haven't
changed with this press release flash
indictment last Friday that's going to
go nowhere but but yeah we that was a
political document to be that indictment
because they know they're not gonna
arrest any of these people but but your
point is well-taken
there is Russian interference there was
and Hillary Clinton's campaign in the
DNC brought the Russians in dr. Gorka
they paid the Russians to be involved in
this short of the trolls apart from the
trolls and why wouldn't the Russians
think they can get away with it after
all
Vladimir Putin put his operatives in
America and they got 20% of our uranium
why would they think anything else
look there are categories from the Cold
War you know the useful idiot category
Michael Moore was a useful idiot when he
shows up at that demonstration against
Donald Trump that
organized by the Russians but we're not
talking about useful idiots when it
comes to the FISA Court surveillance and
the steel dossier here let's use a
phrase from the military Hillary Clinton
her lawyers and the DNC were force
multipliers for Russian propaganda that
attacked a presidential candidate during
an election they weren't unwitting they
were they actually paid for it more than
twelve million dollars of Russian
propaganda paid for and funneled into an
illegal surveillance warrant against a
US citizen I got a roll you guys have
been doing amazing work keep up the good
work we need your voice every night